wow
this is what it's like to be at the
launch of a spacecraft
we have this mission launching the
perseverance rover
and the helicopter ingenuity is going up
on a seven
month uh journey to reach mars this is
just awesome
man my first launch of a spacecraft and
i just feel like i'm the only one out
here it's me and the
spacecraft is right over i don't know
there somewhere i'm gonna put on a long
line so we can see it i think i can see
it
holy crap holy crap
look at it go
that is phenomenal you got any advice
for me in terms of like what i should be
looking out for or
you know any advice for a first-timer so
it's really interesting to me is how
emotional it is
so basically what you're going to see is
is it's almost like a
miracle like you hear it the countdown
and then all of a sudden you see this
light taking off it's like you know it's
like clouds and then you see the light
taking off
and just like well i don't hear anything
all of a sudden you feel it in your body
like that
the sound of course propagating slower
than the light will hit your body and
will really
shake you and you know it's this almost
out of body experience that you're part
of really again
taking off from the shore of the cosmic
ocean
you know so for me it's like you know
punching a hole in the sky
so
that was amazing
and there it is doing its turn to the
east
i felt this for the first time a couple
years ago when i saw
the solar eclipse but there are just
some
moments in life where you realize that
you are really on this
rock hurtling through space the solar
eclipse was one of those moments for me
and
seeing this rocket launch to another
planet
it just hits that home it's like most of
your daily life you can go
and and just do everything without
thinking about that fundamental reality
but when you see something like this
it just changes your world view for a
minute
and so you can really embrace this sense
that we're on this
this rock hurtling through space and we
just sent off a
a projectile to another planet which is
a pretty freaking amazing thing
i know we've done it a number of times
in the past so
you know maybe people get sort of numb
to it but uh
it's in a pretty extraordinary
accomplishment every
every time
you